it's my belief that we're giving the
injections wrong to put it in a very
superficial blunt idiot comedian in the
internet way what's wrong with mRNA
technology
well the main thing is that because we
haven't used it on a mass scale before
there's lots of uh no things we don't
know about it remember Donald Rumsfeld
he said well we've got uh we've got
known unknowns and we've got unknown
unknowns
so there's things that we knew we didn't
know about it but then there's things
that we didn't know we didn't know so
what what's actually happening with
these vaccines is you inject you inject
it now what's supposed to happen is
they're supposed to stay in your arm
maybe a bit go into your lymph nodes
under your arm and generate a localized
immune response there but that has a an
effect on the whole body
but what we now know is happening for
example with these mRNA vaccines is
there actually
um they're actually being systemically
absorbed to a degree they're going
everywhere
so what happens is you've got one of
these lipid nanoparticles with this mRNA
recipe inside for the for the antigen if
that goes into a cell in your arm
that goes into your arm the cell in your
arm makes some of the antigen some of
the spike protein the immune system
recognizes that Spike protein as being
foreign and generates the immune
response and that's good and because
this inflammation associated with the
immune response you're going to get a
sore arm well big big deal you know I
can live with a sore arm
but if the systemic absorption of this
and this is what hasn't been fully
answered at the moment but there is data
that's showing that these are
systemically absorbed
um if the systemically absorbed then
suppose that that mRNA lipid
nanoparticle one of billions
is going through a blood vessel in your
heart for example
then that lipid nanoparticle can come
into contact with a vascular endothelium
inside your heart vessels inside the
blood vessels in your heart
and because the lipid Nano particle has
got a fatty wall and the cells in your
heart have got a fatty wall they will
absorb into each other just let you just
you know when you have two Bubbles and
they just absorb into each other when
you're playing with bubbles it's just
like that the membranes kind of merge
together and that would let the MRNA
into the cells now but not in your arm
now the cells that the MRNA is going
into it could be in your heart
but the same thing will happen the MRNA
is the recipe to make the protein then
the heart cells will make the protein
and the Heart cells will export this
protein onto the surface of the cell and
it will stick onto proteins on the
surface of the cell it's called
presentation so all all cells can be
what we call antigen presenting cells to
some degree then the immune system will
come by and say oh that on this heart
cell there's a bit of a foreign material
a bit of Spike Protein that's not
supposed to be there because that's what
the immune system does it recognize the
difference between itself and what's not
itself and so what it does is it mounts
an immunological reaction to that
foreign Spike protein
but it happens to be in the heart and
when you get the immunity you also get
inflammation going with it and if you
get inflammation in the heart muscle
that's called myocarditis you get
inflammation in the pericardium that's
called pericarditis which we of course
we we don't we don't want these things
so the problem seems to be that the
there is systemic absorption of these
lipid nanoparticles and as well as that
this is another one of my big themes
it's my belief that we're giving the
injections wrong so what you're supposed
to do when you stick a needle in so I've
got might have someone somewhere you
stick a needle it you stick a needle
into someone like that so you stick it
in and then what you're supposed to do
is draw back on the plunger and then if
you're in a blood vessel you'll get
blood going into the syringe about to
see it and then you know not to inject
because the injection that we're giving
for vaccines is supposed to be
intramuscular into the muscle
whereas if you hit a blood vessel
it goes into a blood vessel that will
become an intravascular injection
could be a vein could be an artery more
likely to be a vein and that means it
would be systemically absorbed really
quickly it could go all around the body
and we don't want that so I I think what
we should do is change the guidelines to
say
nurses and doctors vaccine givers stick
the needle in draw back when you're
satisfied you're not in a vessel then
inject it because I think a proportion
of the injections that we're giving are
going straight into a vein and then
we're getting even more systemic
distribution and John the obvious
question therefore is this uh what's the
data on the concerns that you have about
myocarditis and pericarditis
yeah so so there is definitely an
admission now if we take the MRNA
vaccines that they uh it is a risk of
myocarditis and pericarditis now you can
argue about the the levels of these the
problem is that most of the data that we
get after the release of a drug in the
UK comes from what we call the Yellow
Card scheme of course now it's all on a
computer
um but we're still we still have these
yellow cards in the back of the old uh
in the in the back of the books in fact
um if you look in the back of these
the these are the books here with all
the uh all the drugs that you can
prescribe in and still at the back
there's some yellow pages
that you can fill out any uh any Adverse
Events in
although it's mostly done on a computer
now but the British national the British
medical journal actually published an
article
saying that only about 10 of Severus and
serious adverse reactions are reported
and for less serious Adverse Events
probably only two or three percent that
are actually reported so the question is
to what degree is there Under reporting
of these side effects
because very often
um
there seems to be a bit of a pressure
on doctors and nurses not to say
anything bad about vaccines
and as well as that
um as well as that if someone gets
myocardialis or pericarditis
maybe people never thought to ask how
long ago it was since they they had a
vaccine the the connection might not
have been
made so we have Under reporting so we
know we know it causes some myocarditis
some pericarditis we're even allowed to
say that on YouTube now because that
that is known
um the question is is is the amount is
is there significant Under reporting and
what is the risk benefit analysis for
the individual so in hell if I was
treating either of you guys for anything
I wouldn't say well what what is good
you know if a treating constantly I
wouldn't say what's good for Francis and
I'm treating Francis I wouldn't say
what's good for Constantine you treat
the individual
this is the whole point so it's all
about risk benefit analysis for the
individual so the idea that you would
give a young man an mRNA vaccine for a
disease which for them is very very
likely to be trivial never guaranteed
but very very likely that a fit 18 year
old is not going to get very sick from
covert
especially especially a young fit man
who are more prone to the these
conditions
the idea that you would expose them to
that risk of pericarditis or myocarditis
the risk benefit analysis for them
to me just simply doesn't add up and in
fact if you look at the risk benefit
analysis assuming that the risks of
Adverse Events is around about one in a
thousand it basically doesn't add up for
anyone anymore
from a much serious from a much less
serious Omicron infection
so basically times have changed risk
benefit analysis has changed
and I I don't like this idea where
everyone's treated the same so I think
every intervention now especially as
we're not in a crisis situation now
every intervention whether it's a
vaccine or giving a paracetamol or
giving an ibuprofen tablet should be
what is the potential benefit for you as
an individual human being
what is the potential risk for you as an
individual human being
and we know that young men for example
are more prone to myocarditis and
pericarditis and mRNA vaccines with
essentially no risk at all
from uh severe covert especially now
there's a lot of natural immunity around
so the risk benefit analysis should be
calculated on that individualized basis